given the fact that you don't know
yourself and you're deluded in some way
why not pick a delusion that is useful
to you well this is what NLP gets you
neural linguistic programming talks a
lot about presuppositions because you
can't know rather than think about
what's correct what's useful if I
believe I can do that I can do that the
belief is often the thing that makes the
difference did I tell you about the
symbolic truth but literal falsehood
framework no this is cool things can be
symbolically true but literally false
the belief that porcupines can throw
their quills literally untrue porcupine
can't throw its quills the belief that
porcupines can throw their quills is
symbolically true in that it's adaptive
for you to believe it the same as the
behavioral genetics red pill if you
believe that more than 50% of what you
are psychologically is locked in and you
only get to play with this tiny little
sort of cake dressing on the top of it
it's not very supportive in terms of how
you show up in the world even if it's
true so that's something that might be
literally true but figuratively false
belief makes such a huge difference if
you believe in something it gives you
kind of the will to do it to give it a
go